and for those reasons you can literally
sell me out anything about yeah that's a
good point
I am fans of the show I am Caine aka mr.
wonderful I want to be so rich that I
make people nervous when they show me
their inventions I'm a really big fan of
shark tank I have some experience as an
entrepreneur I just have to pitch to
investors and VCS yeah tea is your
Bronco scrub daddy my gravy has a scrub
daddy so I'm about to dip the sponge
into the cold water oh it's a little
stiffer yeah after the cold and I'm
about to dip this one into the warm
water she's a little softer it's a
little bit softer this is not a
one-size-fits-all we need one that's
smiling more this is not smiling hard
enough makes cleaning the dishes fun
it's a cute little guy dishwashers
exists for a reason
for that reason I'm out I would have
said a plus for the cuteness of it for
functionality I mean I could just buy
regular sponge for 50 cents I'm out I
like the packaging it's very colorful it
catches your eyes super affordable
I'll give it a hundred thousand dollars
for ten percent I wanna invest two
hundred thousand for 25% equity hi
perfect I don't know if it's a good
thing when you open up a product and it
has gloves in it now we're gonna try and
fix this thing
using the fiber fix so if it's like your
shovel break any hardware breaks and if
this is a two-person job
what if you're single and home alone
with a cat oh my god it's getting warm
feel it it's like exuding heat okay I'm
gonna try and break this it's like a
cast I can break it
well coke in a different place but it
doesn't quite break at the success where
it had the fiber fix I would use this on
my car feel like if my spoon were to
break I'd just buy another student can
we make this easy user-friendly and
invisible not investing in this I would
not have invested in this this is way
too much ado to repair something I would
invest 90 K at 10% Reviver the world's
first dry deodorant for clothes removes
odors instantly flip on the swipe use
the white side on your clothes and hair
I'm gonna get the perfume out of my hair
it worked
we're shoving a lot of our
acres about a hole lately ah no I don't
smell anything it takes away the snow we
don't have clothing that reeks of
cigarettes I know that's what he
designed it for imagine that shirt they
gave a little body odor on you can just
hope it didn't really work as a result
I'm out
I'm in for 200k 10% equity I'll invest
250,000 to 500,000 for 20% 500,000 for
25% this was super fun and it should
totally be a board game yeah I would
invest in that ten did I have come this
Friday I'll have maybe $1,000 to take
you all but then I have to pay right
never mind I've got about $20 I feel
like I have a future as a shark I can
see that for you you already have the
look
Thanks